Much like Shanks or Blackbeard before him,
Kizaru is an elaborate, carefully constructed
puzzle box of a character that no matter how
closely you look at, always seems to be missing
some essential pieces to reveal its full picture.
This shouldn´t come as a big surprise, since
he only has received very limited screen time
in the story so far.
Thoughtfully planed character development
after all, is one of the most crucial parts
in creating a vivid and capturing story line.
And as we know, what is most needed for genuine
and organic character development, is especially
one thing: Time.
So, one would think that having only limited
screen time for such an enormous cast as One
Piece, would be a striking disadvantage, resulting
in shallow characters with little room for
emotional involvement.
And yet, it´s EXACTLY characters like Kizaru,
Shanks or Blackbeard that have readers most
excited.
So, what is the secret behind this apparent
paradox?
The answer to that is simple: Oda is a master
of mystery.
He takes the apparent handicap of certain
characters in the story and turns it into
a strength.
He makes use of every single panel, that this
character is shown in, to fletch out a certain
image for his audience.
However, compared to characters with more
screen time, he doesn´t give them slow, organic
growth over time.
Much rather he hands us little puzzle pieces
of information about that person.
Based on these pieces you can create a rough
image of the character in your mind.
However, these pieces can be turned and rearranged
in different ways, and thus allow for different
interpretations and perspectives.
A great example for this are all the small
pieces we have gathered for Blackbeard.
Many of them are so different that you can
puzzle together various possible images for
his character.
In some scenes he seems to be goofy.
In others he seems cruel.
And in again others he seems straight out
scared.
This impression of inconsistency is complemented
by his mysterious power to consume multiple
devil fruits as well his ambition to become
pirate king.
It is really barely more than a handful of
clues about who Blackbeard is.
And yet, he might be the most heatedly discussed
character in the entire series.
The same applies to Shanks about whom we also
only hold tiny bits and pieces.
And of course, one of the characters that
can´t be left out of this list, is Kizaru.
Being the Admiral, that we know by far the
least about, with the exception of Ryokugyo
of course, Kizaru is a prime example of how
Oda manages to create amazing characters,
by only giving them a basic set of traits
and leaving the rest ambiguous and unclear.
How fitting then, that Kizaru follows the
path of unclear justice.
And even though, there only is so much that
we know about his personality and role in
the story, Oda has left us enough pieces of
the puzzle to allow us to figure out what
it means.
So, in this video, we will try to put together
the purpose Kizaru has in the story of One
Piece.
And to do so, we will answer the most crucial
question surrounding his character: What is
unclear Justice ? Before we can look at his
ideological concept of morality and justice
however, we first have to understand, who
Kizaru is as a person.
Same as with his fellow admirals, Borsalino
Kizaru is based on a famous Japanese actor.
Thus, his conceptual design is heavily based
on a character played by actor Kunie Tanaka
in his youth.
Beside their strikingly similar lineaments,
their similarities include Kizaru´s outfit,
his birthday and even his real name, Borsalino.
The epithet ‘Kizaru’, he acquired when
rising into the ranks of the admirals.
Same as with his colleagues, this epithet
consists of a color and an animal.
In Kizaru´s case this is Ki for Yellow and
Zaru for monkey, making him the yellow Monkey.
Accordingly, Sakazuki is Aka-Inu, the red
dog.
While Kuzan is Ao-Kiji, the blue pheasant.
Oda chose these animals based on the famous
folktale of Momotaro, who befriended a pheasant,
a dog and a monkey to accompany him on his
journey.
Next to his very interesting visual and contextual
design, Kizaru is without a doubt also one
of the most powerful characters in the world
of One Piece.
In fact, based on his devil fruit, it is actually
quite hard to determine HOW strong he might
actually be.
After all, being light itself, would easily
make him the fastest character in the story.
Additionally, if Oda were to be more or less
physically accurate with his fruit, it would
most likely also make him the most overpowered
character.
However, we can assume that there are certain
limitations to that power.
Nonetheless, we have never seen Kizaru go
all out before, so we don´t know what he
might truly be capable of.
Accordingly, we also do not know a lot about
Borsellino’s past.
There is a single image of him as a child,
suggesting him to be rather kind and smart,
while brooding over a pile of books.
We know that he joined the marines at a young
age, around the same time as Sakazuki.
Similar to his peer, he quickly rose through
the ranks and reached the status of a vice-admiral
at a fairly young age.
The only thing we know about his time then,
is that he was responsible for capturing Arlong
after Fisher Tiger´s death.
Small fun fact regarding this panel: The hat
that Kizaru is wearing here is actually called
a Borsalino, which is the name of Italy´s
oldest manufacturer of luxury hats.
See.
We are learning stuff about the world, while
taking about One Piece.
Isn´t that fun?
Moving on.
The most defining arc for Kizaru´s character
is undoubtably Sabaody, where he is sent after
Luffy´s attack on one of the Tenryubito.
While he has no problem taking on the entirety
of the worst generation on his own, he doesn´t
manage to catch even a single one of them
in the end, being hindered by Rayleigh´s
and Kuma´s interception in his pursuit.
While he is one of the strongest forces present
during the war at Marineford and taking on
the likes of Whitebeard and Marco singlehandedly,
he doesn´t play any major role in the war´s
outcome.
What really stands out about Kizaru´s character,
therefore, are not his actions, but much rather
his personality.
And I´m not gonna lie, it´s one of my favorites
in the story so far.
Oda depicts Kizaru as an easy-going and laid-back
person.
In fact, he is so laid-back, that at times
he appears to be slow in his reactions and
almost slothful, which has resulted in a number
of stoner jokes surrounding his character.
And you guys better put some good ones in
the comments.
What makes Kizaru a true favorite of mine
however, is the fact that he is one of the
rare characters in the story that has a genuinely
sarcastic nature.
He often talks about how scary or shocking
a situation is, but completely lacks the corresponding
facial expression.
In my personal opinion, characters with a
sarcastic take on things are immensely entertaining.
However, they are quite hard to write and
convey to a general audience, which is why
they are so rarely found inside the Shounen
genre.
As a result, this trait gives Kizaru an air
of cleverness and sharpness, in comparison
to other characters that take everything at
face value.
This impression is complemented by his cool
composure.
No matter how intense a situation might be,
he always appears to be in control of his
emotions.
To the reader, this conveys a sense of strong
confidence in his own abilities.
We can see this in his absentmindedness during
battle, not fearing any damage, as well in
his lack of awareness for collateral damage.
Despite his immense battle strength, but maybe
in connection to his laid-back personality,
Kizaru seems to lack personal ambition.
Not only is he the only of the former three
admirals, that doesn´t aspire to become fleet
admiral, he also seems to have no interest
in authority in general.
He doesn´t like giving orders but prefers
receiving them.
We can even see him taking directions from
Sentomaru, one of his own subordinates.
Nonetheless, Kizaru is deeply respected within
the ranks of the marines.
His most defining trait, however, might be
his fearlessness.
Not only does Borsalino take on Whitebeard
and the entire worst generation by himself,
but he even offers to go to Wano and confront
Kaido AND Big Mom on his own.
Something that even Akainu is reluctant to
do.
Now, as mentioned before, all these puzzle
pieces give us a rough image of Kizaru’s
character.
However, we still lack the full image.
For instance, we have no idea what Kizaru
actually values or what his great desire and
drive is.
We have no idea why he joined the marines
in the first place or what his vision for
the world is.
We can´t see it yet.
It´s all.
Unclear.
What we DO know however, is that Kizaru shares
neither Akainu´s sense of absolute justice
and hate towards pirates nor Kuzan´s kind
and forgiving nature.
He much rather appears like an old teacher,
that intervenes and lectures when necessary,
but stays out of everyone’s business otherwise.
We even see him specifically targeting Luffy
to lecture him about the gap between him and
those on the battlefield.
So, based on these insights we have gathered
now, let´s deconstruct what the concept of
unclear justice actually means and what it
tells us about Kizaru´s role in the story.
Based on his personality and the construction
of his character, I would argue that there
are three distinct interpretations of Kizaru´s
concept of unclear justice.
The first one of these is rather straight
forward: Kizaru´s justice is unclear, because
he often seems indecisive and without directions
in his decisions and objectives.
Back on Sabaody for instance, he immediately
delays his mission to look for Sentomaru.
Once Sentomaru contacts him, he goes back
to looking for Luffy, before once again getting
sidetracked by the other supernova.
Once he defeats them however, he doesn´t
bother to capture them, but once again leaves
to find the straw hats, finally ending up
not capturing any of them, but sacking 500
other pirates instead.
It is quite possible, that this stems from
his sense of invincibility.
Which makes you wonder, how powerful Kizaru
truly is, if he´s able to be this unfocused
in his actions.
His way of decision making lacks a clear direction
and strive as Akainu and Aokiji do, which
makes it unclear.
And speaking of his two fellow admirals, this
brings us to the second way of looking at
his justice.
Because it is especially unclear, when put
between the two extremes that are Akainu and
Aokiji.
Kuzan´s justice is unclear, because it falls
on neither side of the spectrum.
He neither follow´s Sakazuki´s absolute
justice, that is built on hatred towards all
pirates and militaristic strictness, nor Kuzan´s
lazy justice, that is based on morality and
fairness.
Instead, as the Sabaody example shows really
well, Borsellino’s sense of justice seems
to be movable on the scale between red and
blue.
Trying to capture the straw hats, failing,
but then capturing 500 other pirates in the
process shows us how his sense of just action
sways between thoroughness and fairness.
While it might be very easy to agree with
one of the extreme positions, Kizaru might
actually be the admiral that is the most objective
out of the three.
Being neither unnecessarily cruel nor unnecessarily
forgiving, Kizaru can be seen as the balanced
middle between Akainu and Kuzan.
Now, obviously this doesn´t take into account
how flawed and unjust the political structure
of the One Piece world is, which might arguably
make Kuzan´s path more justified, at least
for me personally.
But based on the assumption that the marines
are a neutral organization in the service
of the people, Kizaru would bring the necessary
flexibility and flexibility in his actions.
The thing is, that we don´t know what ideals
Kizaru follows and what his dream for the
world is.
Which already brings us to the last meaning
of unclear justice: Oda deliberately keeps
Kizaru´s true nature unclear for us to see.
We still miss a few decisive pieces of the
puzzle to truly understand, who Kizaru is
as a person.
So, I am fairly confident, that Kizaru will
have to play a major role in the future of
the story.
And once, we will learn more about him, we
might also get a better picture of him.